أطلق عليه هوميروس لقب مجد
الخالدين للإنكا ،
فقد كان عرق الشمس الذي
اعتقد المصريون أنه
سيدعمهم في الحياة الآخرة لآلاف السنين ،
وقد أغرى الذهب المستكشفين بدعم
الإمبراطوريات وأصبح مقياسًا للسوق
تنبع قيمته من
ندرته  كل الذهب المستخرج على
مدار الحضارة لن يملأ
أربعة حمامات سباحة بحجم أولمبي
، ظهر رابط مباشر بين الذهب والعملة
في عام 550 قبل الميلاد عندما
تم ضرب العملات الذهبية الأولى في ما هو الآن جزء من
تركيا الحديثة في عملات القرن التاسع عشر
حولها.  كان العالم ثابتًا
على الذهب الذي استمر حتى عام 1971 عندما
أعلن الرئيس نيكسون أن الولايات المتحدة
لن تستبدل الدولار بالذهب
بسعر محدد للمستثمرين على الرغم من أن الذهب
لا يزال يتلألأ في أوقات الأزمات
بقيمة بيت عند 1900 دولار للأوقية في عام
2011 ويطلبه كثيرًا  ارتفاعات كبيرة في أوقات
ضغوط السوق حيث يبحث المستثمرون عن
ملاذ آمن
على الرغم من جاذبية الذهب ليس محصنًا ضد
الحقائق الاقتصادية ، والغرض الأساسي
منه  لا يزال يوم المجوهرات
يسير على خطى الفاتح الإسباني
هيرنان كورتيس الذي قال
إنني ورفاقي أعاني من مرض
في القلب لا يمكن علاجه إلا
بالذهب